hey guys i'm philip molina and after
months of talking about it and
dissecting it Batman vs Superman is
finally here and as I watched the last
and final trailer for it I realized I
actually have a bunch of predictions for
this movie that I haven't even told you
guys about so I'm going to talk about
some stuff I noticed in that final
trailer and a little bit about the other
trailers and TV spots and stuff and some
bonus materials too there's this book
that I checked out lots of stuff that
I'm gonna use to help analyze this
trailer and give some predictions about
some things that are probably gonna be
in this movies now if you haven't seen
it yet you can tell me what you think
about my predictions below but if you're
like I already saw this what do I care
just feel free to grade me on these
predictions try not to hate too hard if
I'm wrong about stuff but I feel pretty
good about some of these all right here
goes let's get to it
last away barrel imaging is showing me
two dozen hostiles on the third floor
why don't I drop you off on the second
so right off the bat pun intended we see
some new technology to Batman's arsenal
he's got this roan operated batwing and
remember in this movie he's way into his
career so all of his tech is pretty
badass at this point this is being
operated by Alfred from the Batcave we
also get a quick look at Batman's
supercomputer which we've now found out
he and Alfred built this thing together
and they keep doing upgrades to it like
they're like Steve Jobs and Steve
Wozniak in a garage somewhere or
something but you can tell actually cuz
look at the old-school keyboard and yet
it also has these newer touch screens
it's got a police scanner built in there
and that really cool drone joystick that
just pops out when you need to take your
drone for a spin again I love that
they're implying that man has been at
this for a really long time and they
keep doing improvements and improvements
it's just a nice way to feel like that
world is really lived in anyway it just
feels like drones are playing a much
bigger role in this movie then obviously
they've ever played in any of these
movies and that's not just because
drones are more in the news these days
even have an actor Dan and Boyer he's an
Air Force drone pilot a lot of people
think you might end up turning out to be
Green Lantern I don't know if that's
gonna happen but also Lex Luthor's
company in LexCorp they developed drone
technology it just feels like a lot of
things are pointing toward drone stuff
whether or not drones play a large role
on this movie
it at least shows they're definitely
updating the surrounding military to
keep up with the fact that this movie is
coming out in 2016 moving on
his next fight scene is immediately one
of the coolest parts of the trailer it's
Batman just like explodes out of the
floorboard he flips the guy over
shoulder II body slams them he tosses a
freaking flashbang grenade he takes out
some other guys throws one guy across
the room punches a bunch of other guys
slings one guy into a wall and then like
lambs his other guy into the floor II
probably breaking that guy's neck like
that guy's definitely dead my point is
Batman is just killing it here I mean
kind of literally and it's so fluid and
such a high level threat a lot of people
complain about the Christopher Nolan
movies that the action isn't really
there at least in terms of Batman's
fighting ability it was definitely under
in a way where you couldn't exactly
follow his fighting because he was kind
of that hide in the shadows ninja style
this is not that this is an epic brawler
that just can take on anyone that
doesn't need to hide at all maybe the
coolest thing about all this fighting
here this choreography it's got to be
inspired by the Arkham game that's the
free-flow fighting style that he uses in
all the games the body slams the flips
the throws the leave I definitely think
they solve those games and we're like
yeah that's a pretty badass looking
fighting style why don't we do that in
the movie and they freakin did really at
the end of the day I'm just happy to see
a version of Batman that doesn't have to
move his whole body just to turn his
frickin head look at that that's
ridiculous you can tell that's not even
his arm on that thumbs up that's not his
arm that's a little he can move 90s were
a weird time it's also just interesting
again to see how much technology Batman
has acquired at this point I'm guessing
here he's using at least different kinds
of batarangs grab my gun from Sleeping
Dogs and smoke grenade he's also got
that like disruptor thing from the
Arkham game he might be using over here
to disable the people's guns we'll get
back to that later and then on top of
that the bat suit which in this version
of it is at least bulletproof it
definitely has these lightweight plates
inside of it that repel bullets but also
the Cape is fireproof and it's
definitely knife resistant you can see
some sparks flying off of his bag and
that all gets assisted by the cowl which
is also full of tag you've got the eyes
they have a part that can drop down that
we see in other part that gives them a
heads-up display kind of thing how like
Iron Man on
wait and then we've heard his voice it
sounds very different that's because
he's got a throat microphone built into
this thing that modulates it for him so
he doesn't have to swallow glass like
Christian Bale did anyway what's really
interesting about all this technology is
the fact that he is now relying on this
technology and his fighting style and
don't get me wrong like I said his
fighting it's insane but the fact that
he's having to maybe use more of these
pieces of technology and having to
invent new ways to have an upper hand
maybe that's why he says this Alfred
ineffective I'm getting slow in my old
age effort even you got too old to die
young not for lack of trying now we saw
a shot of this Batcave and pretty much
every trailer before this one but since
then we've learned a lot of details
about it like this is all underneath his
new house his new Wayne Manor if you
will the old Wayne Manor is all decayed
and destroyed so he since build a new
mansion and this is underneath battle II
partially it's also partially underneath
a lake you can see there's that
waterfall that's not like a rich person
Fung Shui a kind of thing or something
that's basically a leaky roof and each
level has something different on the
lowest level there's like kind of a
garage situation where they keep the
different cars and they're able to work
on them but there's also a whole level
that's just dedicated to basically
science they have tables for repairs and
inventions but there's also tables just
for science experiments and working with
chemicals and this whole design with all
these levels and these are geometric
shapes and all the glass and the falling
water that's all based on Frank Lloyd
Wright's falling water River house which
is literally a house built on a river
now if you're thinking that this is all
like crazy sophisticated something it's
again it makes sense that Batman's been
doing this for 20 years he keeps
improving and changing things and his
Batcave has gone through a whole round
of improvements depending on what he
needed at the time and what technology
was available his old Wayne Manor is out
of the picture and now he's got this
thing that's basically designed just for
him to be the best Batman that he can be
which is also an interesting place to
find him in terms of
humanity you'd let go of the things that
made him Batman before his Wayne Manor
is what was his family life and is very
important in the comics and even in all
the other movies and now he's in a cold
separate situation that is almost
completely removed from anything that
has to do with Bruce Wayne and his
almost built solely just for being
Batman I guess that's what happens when
you lose someone so close to you and you
get lost in your work I'm also loving
how cool Jeremy Irons is coming off his
version of Alfred with his joke here
he's been a little serious and the other
one even you got to old die young
not a lack of trying but here we're
seeing him almost come off kinda like
scar honestly but a lot of us remember
him as the main villain and die hard
with a vengeance
Simon Gruber and what's great about that
is that I feel like he's tapping into
almost that badass that he was in those
movies where Alfred actually is not a
butler in these movies it's actually
true he's now Wayne's head of security
and they kind of rewrote his backstory
so that he wasn't the family Butler he
was a family bodyguard and before that
he worked in British intelligence and he
was in the Royal Marines so maybe it's
like brown leather strap he's got here
he looks like a freakin gun holster
something like Alfred's gonna freaking
shoot a bit trip I guess it could also
just be full of like tiny little
screwdrivers like your glasses or
something by the way this is a much more
badass cool Alfred than we've ever had
and honestly of all the changes you
could make making off forward into a
badass by fast and there's a list it's a
pretty welcome change I think all right
let's keep going
she has the power to wipe out the entire
human race we believe there's even a 1%
chance that he is our enemy we have to
take it as it maps
okay so in that fib we got a lot of
stuff we're pretty familiar with at this
point and we cover a lot of it in our
other Batman vs Superman breakdown
videos but after we see the other angle
of Metropolis being destroyed from Man
of Steel and Bruce running to save the
little baby girl and a shot of the
people on the yeah they lost more
clothes makeup reaching out to me like
he's a sort of Christ figure over all of
that we get this new part of the
exchange between Alfred and Bruce where
he says this we believe there's even a
1% chance that he is our enemy we have
to take it as that absolutely okay I
feel like this is a good place to
explain what a lot of people are calling
the 911 illusions that this movie is
making it is gonna be kind of political
here for a second I don't really care
what side you're on of these politics
I'm just gonna explain to you what
people think is being said in this movie
and how it's similar to what really
happened in our real world so these
images and Bruce's words they're giving
the metropolis battle some real context
in a political way that we can relate to
because a lot of people compare the
imagery from the Man of Steel attack to
the footage of New York City during the
9/11 attacks and in the recent TV
commercials there was a part where Bruce
is really driving this comparison home
count the dead thousands of people
what's next week and then we recently
found out that the Superman statue is
actually on the ground zero location of
the world machine attack in Metropolis
and obviously that's a lot like how at
Ground Zero 9/11 they've since built a
memorial there too but why are they
doing all this it's because they want
Bruce to be the exact same kind of angry
that a lot of Americans were after 9/11
that way he can respond in a way that we
all kind of understand but was the same
kind of weird choice that America made
immediately in response to 9/11 we have
to go to war right away kind of with
almost anyone that we can somehow
connect to this Bruce is even using that
same kind of flawed logic that led the
American government to feel justified in
evading Iraq Secretary of State at a
time Colin Powell showed the UN all
these suspicious photos of Iraq and he
said they might possibly have the
capability to assemble weapons of mass
destruction there that's really not the
same as having nukes in Iraq but that's
kind of like what's going on here if
there's a 1% chance that Superman is our
enemy and we have to treat it as if it's
an absolute certainty we have to go to
war whatever your real life politics are
the reason that there are these
parallels is so that it's at least you
can feel like oh even though this is a
movie about an alien and a kind that
dresses up as a bat fighting and going
to war there are real emotions that do
lead people to make these kinds of
choices because we lived it not too long
ago but enough politics let's move on
greatest gladiator match in the history
of the world
God versus man
day versus night you're psychotic
there's a three syllable word for any
thought too big for little minds then
some more things that we've seen before
but we get a little bit more context
there's the Batmobile skidding past
Superman but before it kind of looked
like Batman was maybe ramming Superman
here in this shot it kind of seems like
Superman's actually caught Batman by
surprise and he's slamming on the brakes
and the Batmobile just have bounces off
of Superman and unfortunately happens to
go straight into the Gotham City gas
station Superman then rips off the door
and we know from that other commercial
that he has probably his coolest line
that he's had in any of these trailers
but that is dead bury it so that bad ass
for his side we kept thinking that
Batman was kind of hunting Superman down
and threatening him like you know David
chase skeptical eyes or something but
this is all starting to make it seem
like Superman is just as interested in
finding Batman in Gotham and letting him
know quit it - game over so it is
interesting to see that they really are
equally after each other
also quick point off of that he doesn't
want the bat signal to ever be in use
again now I feel like Batman is
specifically using the bat signal after
he's been told not to you basically say
feo Superman come at me moving on
you
okay we then see Batman in that new anti
Superman armor bat suit that we've seen
a couple of times but now we know this
thing's made out of lead which is super
heavy too but we've also found out that
there's an internal energy source it's
kind of like how Iron Man is able to use
his suit because it's internally powered
or also how Ripley and aliens is able to
use that exoskeleton because it's got
its own power source so Batman is able
to move pretty easily in this really
heavy lead thing also you got to
remember that lead is the only material
that Superman's x-ray vision doesn't
work on so I'm guessing Batman just
doesn't watch Superman like checking him
out like looking at his junk Batman's
not having that he made this thing out
of lead he also his helmet has that same
kind of wiring that I was talking about
earlier where lenses come down and he
can use night vision infrared none of
that helps because Superman is just
pissed that if already and he just
smashes his fancy new suit through a
building which I know you might be
thinking like hey wasn't Batman
initially pissed about all the
collateral damage and here we are
knocking stuff down but keep in mind
they do seem like they're purposely
fighting in these abandoned construction
area here's the real question though how
is Batman even lasting in this fight and
it looks like Superman's really coming
at him so obviously we're wondering has
Batman actually built a suit that makes
him withstand Superman's punches or what
I think is more likely did Batman do
something to Superman to weaken him just
enough to be able to fight him my guess
is probably and maybe Lex had a hammer
we then start to get into the lives that
these heroes have outside of being
Batman and Superman with Lois and Clark
and also Bruce stealing with his wealth
and reputation and there's a really like
cheeky silly question here that comes up
where you see this thing where Clark
jumps in like fully clothed into a
bathtub with Lois which is the kind of
thing you do when you fall in love and
you're in a movie and you act weird late
but the real question if you are asking
here and it comes up a lot de-bone like
have Clark and Lois been having sex and
it's a silly question that's coming for
as long as Superman has been around and
it's cuz you always wonder oh how is
that even possible wouldn't he just
destroy her and I know Marvel kind of
recently addressed it with Jessica Jones
looks like well when you put two
superheroes together they can go at it
or when the Hulk is getting kind of
excited he actually has to like calm
down because it's not
gonna work so there's just an unspoken
thing here the lot of people are
wondering like how far along are Clark
and Lois in their relationship these
days
I mean I'll admit I'm curious I want to
know maybe this movie will have the
answer to it they did in the Superman
Returns movies managed to have a baby
together so he's able to control himself
some amount we might get another chapter
in this Clark and Lois can they or can't
they Authority when this movie comes out
we get a lot of action in this area but
the thing worth talking about is
definitely that Batman is firing some
sort of gun at Superman's head a lot of
debate again about what kind of gun this
is and the whole reason it's crazy is
because Batman doesn't really use guns
very often kind of sometimes without
really a lot of people think it's a
grenade launcher some people think it's
a freaking gun with a kryptonite bullet
in it which either would make sense
because it would weaken Superman but it
could still be freaking crazy as that
we're true wouldn't that just like blow
his freakin brains out probably not you
probably would survive it it would
probably just weaken but I don't know I
don't know that they'll put a gun in
Batman's hand that has a bullet in it
that is meant to like pierce and go
through Superman if they do it would
show just how much Batman hates Superman
where he is willing to just completely
assassinate him I don't know tell me
what you guys think here what's going on
with that gun it looks like it could be
one of the guns that we've established
before as being not so terrible but it
could be a legit anti alien gun then
again we get a bunch of stuff we've kind
of seen before but in this fight any
quick cut there's some really cool stuff
especially this moment where Superman
blocks this kick and he throws armored
Batman across the room that kick is
exactly a panel in the Dark Knight
Returns and that comic series has one of
the best all-time stories of Batman and
it's really clear just how much
inspiration are getting from that thing
and then again is totally fine with me
it's such a great story I'll put a link
in the description go ahead and buy that
thing and read it it's one of the best
Batman stories in general let alone the
fact that it's a lot of inspiration for
this movie then when we see that
explosion that we've seen before I
started at least think like oh you know
who we don't see in this trailer is
doomsday I feel like DC did that on
purpose because a lot of people
complained about doomsday being too much
and they obviously don't want to show
any more footage and he already showed
of the guy so they kind of lean more to
showing more Wonder Woman footage and no
one's really complaining about that we
can learn a little bit more about Wonder
Woman I think that was a really
deliberate move and I think it was
probably a smart one
I don't think you've ever known likely
we get this new exchange of brews
talking to Diana and it feels like it's
a different moment than we've seen from
them before but what I really like about
it is that obviously they're flirting
like crazy and he says that he's known a
few women like her and she's like not
quite like me what's cool about that is
that you might hear that to think oh
well Bruce has been around but remember
again 20 years of being Batman in this
universe Bruce is probably talking about
some pretty intense crazy lady Selina
Kyle Talia al Ghul he's right he's known
somehow Werfel very charming intriguing
women but she's also right none of them
have been like her and what's really
cool about that is what is she like
she's almost like a God in her own
powered by a goddess she gets her powers
from the ancient Greek gods and if
anything she's very similar to what
Superman is like so it's not just this
complicated thing where he's mad at this
guy and he's having this side loves or a
B story kind of rom-com thing he's
attracted to the exact same kind of
person that he hates and that is gonna
be a really interesting thing for him to
figure out later
remember when she shows up and you know
is she with you she was here when that
happened if he realizes that's Diana
that's gonna actually put him in the
place of like oh crap the whole thing
I've been fighting again it can be
packaged in a much prettier figure with
her so maybe it's not just doomsday that
makes them bury their beef and work
together maybe it's the fact that he
realizes this woman that he's pretty
into is close to his powerful as
Superman and she seems like a good one
right
this next section has this pretty epic
leap that Wonderwoman make she's got
this badass sword now we've since that
out this sword has its own magical
nature and if you remember one of the
only things that Superman is vulnerable
to is magic so yeah that sword could
theoretically be used against him but if
he can be used against him and he's a
Kryptonian who's the other Kryptonian in
the movie General Zod is used to create
doomsday so maybe that sword that she
has is part of the key to defeating
doomsday we'll see then there's this
moment where Lois looks like she might
drown and I definitely think there are
foreshadowing this in the earlier
bathtub scene but a lot of people think
that there's more going on in this shot
than we can tell there's like an orange
below at the bottom that looks like it
could be maybe Doomsday's version of
heat vision or something or some people
think aquaman might show up in this
moment but also remember that and the
other trailers we've seen there's a lot
going on with the water board doing some
sort of testing and there's all that
water coming off of that building that
looks like it's using Doomsday's
creation I feel like water is going to
play a major role in the plot of this
movie then we go back to that fight
scene that we saw earlier where you
jumped up to the floor and won I love
this point of view where he looks down
on them from the rafters like he's
stalking them like some sort of predator
but - he uses what looks like here could
be a disrupter to disable all of their
guns and that would be another direct
reference to the Arkham video games
alright let's keep going
Lyonne American
but power can be innocent and then we
see some more stuff we've seen before
and remember I know I'm skipping a lot
of this stuff but we've covered a lot of
it and our other trailer breakdown so
I'm trying to stick to mostly the new
stuff so here in this section the part
that actually worries me the most is
Martha Kent being very shocked and then
dropping a pot of coffee then we see
Lois consoling Superman I'm really
worried about Martha Kent he lost his
dad back in Man of Steel the only thing
they could do they're not gonna get rid
of Lois are they gonna kill Martha Kent
or at least hurt her severely I kind of
hope not just cuz I really like Diane
Lane in that role especially now that
she's coming off a little bit tougher
than Martha Kent has come off sometimes
in the past yeah but I don't know like
they want it to be really legit serious
yeah I kill the guys mom and he's gonna
be freakin furious is that said I don't
think Batman would do that again I'm not
confirming that she dies but if she does
who do you think doesn't then we get
more of that desert sequence this again
is probably a dream but we get this wide
shot of Batman over looking like this
haribol skyline and everything just got
a hell then you see that huge Omega
symbol and it's all obviously a
reference to Darkseid and all of this
suddenly reminded me of something in the
comics Darkseid travels to the distant
future and is just destroyed everything
and that kind of feels like what could
be going on here it doesn't look like
modern day or has been destroyed it
looks like it could be the distant
future I wonder if they're borrowing
that storyline if they are bringing in
this time-travel stories that actually
aside from the flashpoint stuff with
flash we haven't seen that much of that
in the DC Universe not in the comics
like in the films or the TV show so
would feel like an original story to do
with the Justice League I wonder if
they're going to do that time-travel is
a pretty big way to save yourself apart
from the Marvel movies too
and then finally we get to the craziest
shot from this entire trailer Batman
blah Superman's punch and right there a
million nerds we're like what like the
same face that Superman makes a bunch of
nerds made except Superman has a very
handsome chiseled face and us nerds are
more like duh hi we still we're all
equally as shocked as he was and again
it brings up that question how is that
man doing that when you're watching this
it does feel like this is in the middle
of that fight that we've seen a lot of
footage from throughout the rest of the
trailer so does it feel like maybe
Batman has done something in the middle
of that fight too suddenly we can
Superman well maybe it was a kryptonite
bullet or kryptonite something that it's
finally taking effect now made so Batman
actually is stronger than Superman that
would be very crazy but it would totally
level the playing field and it's a
really unlevel one to start with so it
actually is kind of fair that he was
fight dirty if you know what I mean
also I just want to point out like I
said we've seen a lot of this fight from
the trailers but we also saw a lot of
that Deadpool action scene from the
trailers the one on the highway and
honestly when I saw the movie I still
really like that whole scene and there
was a lot of stuff we didn't see and it
still totally lived up to it so I think
there's enough that they're not showing
us in this big epic fight scene and I'm
still really pumped about it there's no
way they showed us the best moment it's
gonna be this huge epic fight scene at
least that moment is gonna live up to
the whole Batman vs Superman hype maybe
it'll only be that scene it lives up to
it or maybe not
but we'll definitely find out pretty
soon all right guys I know there was a
lot of stuff that it felt like I just
kind of skipped over but again we
dissected the hell out of that same
footage and our other Batman vs Superman
video go watch another video I analyzed
everything including the freakin artwork
in the background but if there's
anything I did miss from this trailer
specifically that is not in the other
trailer definitely hit me up on Twitter
at fimo you can also let everybody else
know in the comments below and follow at
new rosters to find out when our videos
are coming out I'm gonna throw one last
question at you
feel like I already started a big fight
as soon as I that question let me know
what you guys think that's it until next
time thanks for watching bye